committee on part seven of SB
133 I find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with houseo 67 the govern's
emergency order number 12 pursuing to
executive order 20204 this public body
is authorized to meet electronically
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe contemporaneously this meeting
over in accordance with the emergency
order confirming that all members of the
committee and select legislative staff
the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through Zoom elic meeting platform and
the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary to participate in this meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website this notices for
the meeting applies with house rules and
RSA 91a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 or email HC c s
l.st
do. Us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled we that all
votes that are taken to this meeting
should be done by roll call vote start
the meeting by taking rooll Co
attendance for each member states their
presence please also State whether there
is anyone in the room with that member
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law uh members
Maguire okay representative
o'ban present I am uh in Nash and I am
Judy you were here representative Judy
going
once speak to us
please I'm here my
wife okay
no not present at this time uh the uh
scitec is here in the room uh other
members of the adna committee are are
observing uh and who are invited to
participate they are that I see
representative
Bailey I'm at home alone representative
um Terry Roy Ro Terry Terry
Roy I am here by myself terrific thank
you representative Roy uh representative
Schmidt I am H present at my office in
Dover but I and I am
alone okay are there any other members
here well okay representative Coy are
you announce yourself and my wife in the
other room and representative SAS did
you say Lara Lara I'm sorry good morning
uh home and
alone okay I don't know that their pres
required always welcome to listen and
see
well oh of course that's true but I'm
talking about
whether more information is desirable um
we are here uh as advertised to
study section seven Romans 7 of the
omnus SD
133n and starting on page 41 it starts
on page 41 and I'm hoping that people
from the oplc are here in particular Mr
Porter and Mr bro they are both here and
they are both able to
speak
okay I would like to start by going over
my comments my take on the
vill uh and uh then invite others either
to interrupt as appropriate or to then
uh chime in after I've uh as after I
finished or as I proceed this is uh
uh I want to accomplish things I'm not
too concerned about the formalities of
things I'm going to say initially uh to
Mr Brad and to Mr uh Porter that I
thought going into this that this would
be just going over it technically and I
think there's more to it than that it
maybe my experience speaking but the
fact is experienced or not I have to
make a judgment I'm going I ask you to
help me with that judgment or to make
the appropriate
changes think I because at this time I
see a lot of trees but I don't have a
cohesive Forest yet I'll tell you the
principal issue that I have there are
two uh things issues that sort of
occurred to me before but as I read
during the hearing um I'll develop them
now
first it
appears that the policy has been changed
that the oplc is going to conduct the
investigation in the past it was in
collaboration in cons consultation with
the board in the past I believe or in
the present not changed yet it is the
board that conducts the entire
process uh now that uh if that's true
and if we adopt that policy there is the
there is an intended problem and that
problem is
that boards presently have if I have
this understanding correct the boards
presently have this investigative power
nowhere is that repealed so you're going
to have two people or the legis the law
will reflect two people having the
investigative Authority different
different representative McGuire is uh
[Music]
here I was just agreeing with representa
kitech
that the first thing I thought of when I
went through this section was there
ought to be a whole bunch of
repeals so that we don't have
conflicting
statutes
and well let's invite them to comment
yeah
comment Tommy you can just unmute
yourself um I I can let uh Mike Porter
go first so
um this is Tom Brodrick speaking on as
legal counsel for the oplc um Michael
Porter attorney Porter is an
administrator three in the enforcement
Division and he might be best able to um
well to speak from the enforcement uh
side and explain what's going on over
there and um I'm happy to speak to any
remaining
pieces let me understand the characters
here Mr brck you're legal counsel what's
Mr Porters in Portsmouth office what's
this
about I don't understand who he
is um
so um the boards to this gets a little
bit to your your first part of the
question about that um who's conducting
the investigation a lot of our boards
previously um used to work with a
division of the um AG's office called
the administrative prosecutions unit not
all of our boards would um I think it
was 10 or 12 did and the boards those
boards that worked with them would send
cases the board would decide uh whether
to investigate a matter they'd send the
case to Apu to to
investigate um AP would drop a report
and send it back to the board and they
would um and then the board would make
the decision on whether it needs further
investigation whether to um move forward
with discipline or whether to send a
letter of concern the decision was all
up to the
boards uh Michael Porter is in the
enforcement unit of the oplc which um is
taking on that role so the
administration administrative
prosecutions unit at the AGS is um I
believe uh they're they're not going to
be working with the boards anymore and
so our enforcement unit is and they are
going to be doing essentially the same
thing but supporting all of our boards
rather than only those 10 um I think
Mike can U Mr Porter can give a lot more
detail there but that's sort of the
grand so Mr Porter sort of subc is a
subcontractor for the Attorney
General handling
enforcement do you want me to explain
please yes yes okay so so I I am so we
no we I'm going to go back a little bit
here we are not subcontract contractors
oplc that was image that wasn't
reality
oh all right um so what I want to
explain is
um what we our our function is to ass
assist the boards okay so for example
I'll I'll use board of psychology Board
of mental health uh real estate
appraisers um they have I believe board
of psychology Board of mental health
have subcommittees which are they're the
investigative unit for those particular
boards the real estate appraiser board
uses a recused board member for those
investigations as well um but there are
other boards such as Board of Nursing
Real Estate Commission and and many
others who want want us as investigators
to conduct the investigations draft the
ROI and then what we do is we then bring
that to a recused board board member for
final review and then that board member
brings the information to uh the full
board to determine whether the matter
should be dismissed a letter of concern
or go forward for Pro for administrative
prosecution so we are not removing
investigators from the boards many
boards do utilize uh their own board
members recused board members as
investigators the Dental Board in fact
used uses a contract
investigator um who is either a dentist
or hygienist and I apologize for not
knowing um and the Board of Medicine
utilizes the mrsc the medical review
subcommittee to conduct their
investigations but we are there to
support them if they need assistance
with drafting a subpoena uh maintaining
you know files assisting with interviews
um if the board member wishes one of our
investigators to accompany them to an
interview inter uh we do so but at the
same time we also provide investigative
uh resources to other boards um who want
to use our investigators so I hope that
clarifies we're not taking any Authority
away from any of the board members to to
conduct their
investigations Mr Porter I think You'
said it well let me just see if I've
power paraphrase this right sure
correctly every board still always has
still retains and even under this bill
would still retain the authority to
conduct its own
investigations in so for some boards
they choose to use opl's enforcement
which is also investigative I guess
division uh support which is you yes and
then you would report back to the board
with your findings and the board would
decide whether they have enough or need
more to proceed is that
right that is a great synopsis yes now
that's a thank you the thanks but what
I'm looking for is that supported in
that's got to be supported in present
statute
right so it it is and under 310a with
the administrative functions um I can
let Tom speak to the the statutes that
govern oplc he is far more U okay I'm in
danger of belaboring this point at this
uh I represent yeah I think that in many
cases it's not 310a it's the specific
statute of each board like the
psychologists are under 329b colon 22 is
all about
investigations that that's correct and
that is a board uh along with a board of
mental health um who have I'll just
refer to them as subcommittees um I
believe the board of psychology has the
PCI
um and they
conduct they're unique from all the
other boards in that they receive
allegations first which do not
necessarily require a response um if the
board then determines that that the
allegation Rises to the level of a
complaint um then there's a required
response and all of that information
goes through the PCI for board of
psychology um and they conduct the
investigations our would assist with the
prosecution of the so for the board of
psychology um our unit would handle the
legal aspect of it um if a case had to
be prosecuted our prosecution unit would
handle that
prosecution okay well Tom I'm very
concerned that this section does not say
things like that so um it I think to so
sorry representative McGuire uh you had
specifically mentioned the board of
psychologists I believe this is in each
of our boards but when um when the oplc
was created in
2015 all oplc all staff that used to be
employed directly by the boards were
transferred to uh under the oplc so if
you look at 329 B22 this is the board of
psychologist statute subsection three
this is specific to investigations after
determining the nature and scope of an
investigation or hearing the board May
employ or retain hearing off officers
legal counsel medical advisers um school
psychologist advisers or investigators
through the office of professional Li
Insurance
certification um so I believe there's
similar Provisions in each board I need
to go through through them all but um I
hope that answers the question as to the
authority the current Authority for oplc
to be assisting boards with
investigations when they want assistance
I understand the bo the oplc can assist
but reading this statute it doesn't
clearly link to the board's Authority it
appears it appears to me and I'm not a
lawyer I don't even play one on TV but
this sounds like the off the oplc will
take command of the process from you
know opening the mail with a complaint
in it and you know not not the complaint
stage when the complaint is going to be
investigated the oplc takes over no no
it well it's not clear it says upon
written complaint of any
off I'm concerned that we are going to
have conflicting statutes okay okay uh
rep we hog this let representative
Schmid
speak thank thank you very much I had my
hand up for a while uh and I'm not sure
it's being seen so that's why I spoke up
after a while so uh what we're
discussing what you've been discussing
up to this point is clearly very
significant and needs to be worked out
uh to the satisfaction of the Legal
Eagles uh but we uh we um certainly want
to participate with our experience but
the thing I've been concerned about all
along is not this although was not a
matter that I disregarded or didn't care
about but the the concern I have is with
regard to the effectiveness of the
investigation um from a technical
standpoint not from a legal standpoint
uh because uh the oplc can't possibly uh
in its enforcement arm have the
expertise of all the boards with regard
to the the the nuts and bolts of
misconduct or bad practice practice or
whatever uh that it would have in some
cases not in others and the boards
clearly have that expertise um among
their personnel uh and so that's what
I'm most concerned about is is that we
not lose somehow in the generalization
and the provision of of enforcement uh
we not lose the expertise required to
determine whether somebody is an
effective uh a practitioner of the
particular profession or or occupation
so that is something that that only the
boards are likely to have um and so
that's what I want to bring up at this
point to make sure that that aspect does
not get lost it I don't hear it being
disregarded at this point but I don't
hear it being clearly enunciated either
so I want everybody to think about that
as well thank you we haven't gotten
there yet I I I realized that but I I
want to make sure because I can't stay
for this whole thing because I have a
conflict but I want to make sure that
that aspect does not get overlooked um
because it sounds like the board is
going to be involved uh but it's C it
needs to be enunciated thank you well
that that's exactly representative
Schmidt I think we're all talking sort
of the same thing that I'd like to see a
statement in the uh in this rewrite or
this update that says the board shall
have plenty has shall have Authority or
has the
right ability to conduct the
investigation with the Assistance or may
ask the assistance consult with
something like that is we we we really
need to clarify what the boards do and
what the um oplc does and Mr Porter had
raised his hand earlier
I'm sorry I I'm having trouble I'm
having trouble with hands we need a
giant not with not standing paragraph
somewhere yes Mr Porter
please thank you and I just wanted to uh
address something that representative
Schmidt did say and and I think and he's
right you know um and we are certainly
not going to sit here before you and
tell you that we um are the experts in
in 55 different professions and that is
why
it is it is
key that the communication with the
boards and the investigative arm um are
working as a cohesive unit and and I and
I'll tell you something I learned
recently was uh we had a real estate
appraiser meeting uh with the board
administrator for that board and um I
ended up until about nine o'clock the
night before going through all the
federal regulations that are in play
never mind the state statutes right um
and the federal audits that are
conducted and and the importance of
those so um Cas boards such as real
estate appraisers uh board of psychology
Board of Mental Health Board of Medicine
um it is vital that our communication
remains open and consistent with those
those boards or
subcommittees um because they are the
experts in the field and we are here to
support them and do what is necessary
but I also want to talk about when I say
enforcement we also have a prosecution
arm um of that we we have two attorneys
currently Prosecuting and um you know
that comes down to Simply a matter of
statutes but I do want to emphasize we
have every intention of continuing to if
boards wish to do their own
investigations we'll be supportive if
they wish for us to interview Witnesses
on their behalf we're happy to do
that uh absolutely I think we're all on
the same page in the sense that there
was no intention as I read it as I or as
I hear you of usurping the board's
Authority I think you've made that clear
the problem is I don't know that the law
that as WR the bill as written makes
that as clear as you have just
enunciated it and I would like first for
myself I would like to see this somehow
Rewritten I don't have the words for it
but I want a clearer statement of what
you have just said I don't think the the
bill as written is as explicit or as
forthright as you have been just now and
I'm GNA I think we've made that point
I'd like to yeah I would strongly agree
with with representative citec and I
think
um Tom you you would you would be the
right person to to put in
a another Clause that they about the the
process and how and bet how it relates
to to the boards and does not usurp the
existing statutory of the board because
is without a such a change this would be
read as being later than the
investigatory processes of the boards
and therefore would supplant them and it
doesn't sound like that's what we want
to do and Tom does that uh uh Mr BR Tom
um thank you um so yes I I'm happy to
help draft something like that I I will
point out as Mike had said and is
abundantly clear the intention was not
to do that that for instance page 41
line line 30 which represented Maguire
you had pointed out before if you go up
two lines before it makes clear that
boards have that Authority um page 42
lines 30 it says the board May dismiss
the complaint not it's not decision made
by oplc but I'm happy to take a look at
this retool it to make that um much more
out front I think the the big picture
and I it sounds like the committee
probably understands this is um uh
starting to or or there's various issues
that that are in all the different
practice acts that that
um yeah that
well I'm not sure exactly how to to to
word this like this statute right here
or this bill is here um incorporates
what is in most board statutes there's a
few boards that are missing pieces of
this right now um for instance um the
large majority of our statutes board
statutes make clear that investigations
while they're ongoing are are
confidential and not disclosable under
91a some board statutes lack that
language and um
I believe the the correct read of that
and read of 91a is that those are still
confidential because it's a
investigation um but someone could
challenge that in in court someday and
um if we can give that protection to all
of our boards investigations um I think
that's a benefit and this is this is a
way to do that so that's just one
example of um a piece that we're trying
to get for every board absolutely I take
that I also recognize that
representative goalie and rep and Dr
Warner want to speak but let me just
throw in that while you said uh you've
cited line 30 says that they still have
they can dismiss I still I think there's
wiggle room there and I'm not content
with that I think we still need to talk
about a rewrite but I now want to move
to representative goalie
please did you want to speak
representative
goie yes thank you Mr chair
um and on that same topic that you're
speaking to on lines 30
3132 um I I look at it
as um when you look at line 31 in in
consultation with the board the office
shall assign an investigator there's no
wiggle room there who who shall complete
the investigation in accordance with
rules um maybe it should say may assign
an investigator because the board may
not want them doing the investigation
they may want to handle it on their own
um and I just also look at if you look
at page 42 um line two for the purpose
of carrying out investigations the
executive director is authorized to
retain experts conduct inspections on
places of businesses um to me it's
taking
the uh Authority from the board and
giving it totally to the executive
director to do that investigation the
way I read
it okay and the only other thing I want
to bring up is I'm a little uh concerned
that we haven't heard from any of the
boards about this going on and this bill
coming forward and that's just a little
concerned that nobody's stepped up to
even uh speak about it Dr Warner is here
representing the Psychiatry board and if
she will stop waving psychology board
and if she will stop waving her hand we
will get around to her representative
goalie terrific before I rep recognize
uh uh representative War Dr W how about
something like uh I
I'm really interrupting the show here uh
the board shall conduct an investigation
which may request the assistance of oplc
I think that is where I'd like to see it
that's that it stays with the board with
the assistance of opy which may Dr
Warner you're at that oh thank you very
very much I appreciate it um Dr Debbie
Warner I serve on the board of
psychologists and um I appreciate the
opportunity to address this subcommittee
um looking at part seven of Senate Bill
133 um I just in terms of the support
that we receive from oplc it is great um
wonderful wonderful Personnel um they
just do fabulously all the time for us
um looking at this this bill this
section though I do have concerns that I
and I they reflect very much the uh
concerns of those mentioned already um I
just want to say I don't think that many
things in this section are needed at
this instant except perhaps for what
attorney brck just mentioned in
protecting certain investigations from
91a disclosure but the um the oplc is
new
and the enforcement unit is very new and
they've been marvelous with us and we're
learning as we go but I I think this
legislation section may be
premature um we're in sort of the beta
enforcement they're learning as they
mental health are very similar because
our statutes are almost the same and I
just want to say I won't talk long would
you please repeat that you broke up
along the
way at least for me oh okay um let me
connection left withing the oplc efforts
and we largely agree it's the question
of what the words say that is bothering
us not what the oplc is not
bothering yes they're
new they're they're marvelous um
attorney Porter has assisted us in a
several ways already in just the several
months that he's been with the
oplc and uh we're
developing our methods and of course he
has to do this with 55 boards I do not
envy this uh position that he's in um
and I do understand that in some ways
oplc needs to have
some um
reproducible um modules of action that
will work across the boards I think that
this is a good first draft of something
to launch from but it's going to take
interconnecting with and examining this
in light of all of the boards to see how
this will work in the long run I think
that it's premature to bring this
forward now in this section I think the
only things that are particularly needed
right now are what attorney brck
mentioned which is the U protecting
investigatory information for certain
boards from disclosure on
91a but there's so much uh going on here
and changing I think that the
enforcement unit that we have today is
going to very different than the one we
will have in six months or even 12
months and they will have gotten even
more brilliant at what they do and it
will I think that this is a good beta um
template for something that we might
consider uh developing for a uniform
approach for assisting the boards and
that certain boards might be be part of
the um we help the training wheels
approach and then the other certain
boards you're on your own you know go
hiking um we that we might have
different conditions or different
sections for that I was very concerned
reading
it um in terms very similar to
representative Maguire's concerns that
this really appears to need to um repeal
all sorts of sections of
our statute and it overrides 22 and
various others it seemed um although in
talking with attorney Porter I very much
appreciate your very early morning um
conversation sleep is something I guess
you don't get when you're working in
your division um but I I appreciate that
and I appreciate the the people involved
have excellent Good Will toward the
boards however reading the Lang language
it doesn't reflect all of the same
limitations that you were conveying to
us verbally and that you you are
portraying and you do in your actions uh
it's continuous you're you're not
hypocritical you you do what you say and
it's very much appreciated but I don't
think that's reflected in this language
and deferring to the board's Authority
and deferring to the board's statutes I
think really needs to be part of this
and so I I would suggest to this
committee that this um part of the bill
be greatly honed down to just the Bare
Essentials that are needed now that the
enforcement unit continue to rely on
standing orders from the boards to do
its work as well as uh particular orders
I know our board doesn't do many
standing orders Debbie thank you it took
you quite a while but you got to our
Point that's exactly what we're talking
about we want right now oplc is not too
big for its britches but we don't want
the a careless law to let this we don't
want our first step to be a careless
step we want it to be crafted and I
think we can do that and still and
address the concern that you've started
that you've enunciated we can we can get
this so that right now we maintain the
confidentiality but that the onus the
right is explicitly stated that the
board has the
investigation has complete Authority
with the assistance the enthusiastic
assistance which they'll probably seek
from LPA oplc but I want the horse in
front of the car yes I see I see a hand
over there are two of them frck and
porer have both raised their hands mean
Mr uh I don't know bradrick go
[Music]
ahead unless you actually I I don't have
my hand up right now um I have a few
things but I can let uh Mr Porter go
first keep your hands to yourself for
now uh repres Mr
reporter oh thank you very much I'm only
on my first cup of coffee um I I wanted
to address uh representative goalie's
concern um with regard to that the the
the sentence that says in consultation
with the board the office shall assign
an investigator and I won't read the
whole thing I I see where the concern is
and I think when when this was drafted
and and again words matter um by the by
the phrase in consultation with the
board to me indicates that we've reached
out to the board they've reached out to
us and they've said hey OPC we need
assistance um if they ask us for
assistance we shall provide that and I
just wanted to clarify um but I do
understand representative goalie's
concern with that word but I just wanted
to give kind of a little bit of input as
to what the the intention was so
that said would it be fair to say would
it be fair to say that that should
actually read when requested by the
board the oplc shall assign an
investigator yeah and and that's
something I'll definitely tell you know
Tom and I can talk about offline as we
go through this um because we will
obviously go through this um for sure so
we can definitely Wordsmith that um as
far as the prematurity of this um
and the the reason this is coming
forward is because we do have 55
different boards that we are working
with and um there's a lot in here that
really addresses issues that not every
board has and I think I mentioned it
during my testimony yesterday unlicensed
practice that's a big problem in this
state with well any state actually um
not every board actually has that and to
have the ability to have something like
that uh present for each board through
this rule writing um I think would help
curb that that illegal practice um so I
just wanted to point out that one issue
as well um Mr Porter we haven't gotten
there yet that's in the bill and I'm
pres I'm gonna Moy along to that in the
time I'll stop then thank
you yeah I would like to say I don't
think it's premature I believe that
since we are creating this division of
Investigations that we need to have a
law that says what they're supposed to
be doing and
while and I think the first and most
important thing is a
leadin says you know the boards have the
responsibility and the technical
Authority and the board and OPC is just
there to help and that is what is the
first thing we've got to have because
otherwise the boards that have well
fleshed out laws and investigative
procedures there are some will not be
influenced by this but the boards that
don't have that statutory Authority or
don't have a well flesh out procedure
division okay uh somebody I think one of
you said word smithing I'm going to get
to word smithing in a minute but this is
may only be a few words but it's fairly
sign is more significant than wordsi to
me I don't think you meant it any I
don't think you meant to minimize it but
we're really I we've spent 40 minutes on
this point which is probably the most
important point of the bill as far as
I'm
concerned up okay uh yes Tom were you
yes thank you and um I just a couple
again bigger things and maybe we'll get
to them but um yeah um sorry uh Mr or I
think it was you chairman uh that had
mentioned that um sorry that the boards
that have good processes um we'll retain
those and we definitely want the good
processes to stay um but that brings up
another point with um you know with 54
different boards with 54 sets of
different um procedures set forth we
have for instance um they may all be or
they a lot of them may be good
procedures but um they can be different
so we have may have one board that says
you have to send notice to a leny um
that a hearing is going to be held
within 30 days of the hearing another
board may say 14 another board may say
45 all in their rules it's it's
difficult I believe for our staff to um
go into each board and keep track of
okay the notice requirement for this
board is this long this board is this
long and and the related piece of that
is um and this is for any of you
especially for any of you on jail car is
that if there's a statutory change that
requires a change to um to the
investigation procedures for the boards
we currently have to go into 54 sets of
rules and change change that and um the
rul making process is a difficult
process
um and for more procedural general rules
I'm not sure that makes
sense what doesn't make sense sorry to
to right now um I if there was a change
to
541a um that laid out a different um
process that boards need to follow for
investigations or hearings um I would
need to change 54 different sets of
rules um or you change the leg
legislation say boards have the right to
ass sign dates for hearings or set dates
for hearings and these these issues
could be handled one at a time but I
would also suggest that if there are
some boards that have
um poor or
no investigative
procedures that we delete the statutes
authorizing them and allow this to cover
them I mean you've got a wide range of
cap ability between the boards some of
them like the Board of Medicine and the
board of psychology have welldeveloped
investigatory
procedures uh I don't know
about the the Midwifery Council for have
her sakes we always use that as the
example but there's got to be some of
the boards where the statutes
are minimal and the rules are uh they
don't really do much in the way of
Investigation
if I if I if I may get back to Tom
that's interesting what you've just
talked about but it's not our point
of who has Authority ultimate Authority
for investigation and discipline and I
welcome re echoing uh responding to
Debbie Warner's point that oplc has been
wonderful to work with I still want the
law to say that and it doesn't matter
whether there're 54 or 540 agencies that
can be specified in the law the other
issues you talked about sure they're
complicated I don't know what we'll do
about that but that's not the Focus
right now the focus is um who's in
charge of Investigations and who assists
and for me as far before I can support
this I want to see this I'll use the
good faith term words SM to reflect that
so that it does not supplant any
existing Authority that oplc that the
present procedure continues but I want
that uh so unless I hear from others on
the committee or everybody's chairman as
far as I'm concerned on my subcommittees
if I don't hear anything else I'm going
to
ask uh I'm gon to ask the subcommittee
how do you feel uh representative uh
Judy representative Maguire and I about
ask oh o' Brian I'm sorry uh
about
recrating or putting some introductory
statement or
redrafting oh good morning
representative sh um redrafting this so
that it is what we've talked about is
clear not implied but
clear yeah is that do we I strongly
agree with you uh representative uh
O'Brien how do you feel about
that uh no I agree uh there seems to be
some problems I think uh we have
identified them and I think it uh we'll
be able to come up with a solution uh
with the help of Mr Porter Mr brck I
hope
Andes representative Judy how do you
what how do you feel about asking uh the
oplc people to draft uh language making
explicit
represent
yes yes the
language the language for me because we
have H one of uh uh I forgot his
name uh who really really uh
touch me when he explained what's going
on in the O
oplc so I think reporter yes I have
to you got it to okay uh yes I would
agree because both Dr Warner and I when
we read through this assumed that it was
the procedure and the existing board
just procedure procedures would have to
be repealed and since that's not the
intent uh I think it needs to be way
more explicit okay uh Mr broadrick Mr
Porter Tom uh Mike do you is this
resonate with you can you do this for
us yeah I um we're happy to go back and
take a look at this and get uh get
something back to the subcommittee okay
great thank you I think we're G have
another session we will okay uh now
there are other issues that I have un
with the bill and I'd like to go along
start proceed with them and invite the
subcommittee to
either interrupt or bring up their own
as I proceed through the bill okay that
sound
reasonable all right
um the there is a question of
confidentiality running through of this
I'm not going to develop that because I
don't I think
that's that doesn't have this I think
that's clear the things are
confidential except until well let me
wait
first on page 42 line
18 it says the office report May
disclose information required to law
enforcement or Health licensing
agencies uh
under what
conditions now I'm pointing out that all
of everything that we're reading here is
new law so this is I'm not we're not
dealing with existing statute everything
from I one j g i one is inserted in A3
where A1 this is all new it say this is
all new so I think I'm sort of perhaps
I'm apologizing for the question but I'd
like to see under what should there be a
statement subcommittee what do you think
should there be a statement uh that this
information that's disclosed there
should be circumstances under which that
is
done you imagining problem here no I it
it I think it should be clearer that law
enforcement I mean if you find evidence
of a crime yes that would be that's one
thing but
um
if there's if you've got innocent people
involved you don't necessarily want to
re reveal their information while you're
at it or to or to Health licensing
agencies I I think that needs some uh s
uh representative O'Brien and
representative Judy we're doing the
talking here but I want to make sure
that what I'm saying is okay with you
that I'd like to see a condition or some
some conditions applied to uh line 19
and for that matter I want to hear if
representative Schmidt and goalie are
still here representative Shu I invite
anybody on the Edna Comm anyone to
comment on what I've just said Mr
chairman if I may go ahead H thank you
um yeah I can see the concerns with this
but then I you know with the usual
caveats you know I don't want to give
private information particularly if
somebody is Innocent but at the same
time we talked about yesterday with
compact ta and other things where
somebody uh might have an issue in
another state uh and they may call up
New Hampshire and say what's going on do
you have any uh any complaints about
this particular provider or something
with this limit an investigation from
another state to come in to you know
help weed out the bad practitioners if
that was the
case well that that has to do with the
investigation I'm thinking now things
uncovered in the
investigation I would like to I you're I
think you're not disagreeing with the
fact that there should be some circum
they just can't the law should say there
are conditions under which this
information is yeah you're correct yes
thank you Mr you're correct in that
summary but I don't uh I want to make
sure that the board has the capability
to do what I think we intended to do to
have the investigation uh
and I think that's enough to say about
that right now uh representative Judy do
say tell you what I will proceed and if
you have if anyone has uh comments
objections uh some you got four hands up
oh I didn't well I'm having trouble with
hands that's why I'm I'm listing for you
I'm sorry uh okay let's
did you wish to speak uh Dr War uh yes
yes the language that you're talking
about on that line um there's similar
language in our statute 329 the 22 Roman
1 the second half of that paragraph
includes a similar thing but it has the
conditions that representative Maguire
was seemed to be concerned about and it
says here the board May disclose
information acquired in an investigation
to law enforcement only if it involves
suspected criminal activity to Health
licensing agencies in this state or any
other jurisdiction if the leny has or is
seeking additional licenses or as
required by specific statutory
requirements or court orders um so that
is more specific and you know might help
your
concern and that help uh because I I'm
going to be I will ask unless the
subcommittee uh doesn't feel the way I
do that this should that that a
condition such as
included I I agree okay uh and
representative Brian said much the same
also okay as I said I think I'll proceed
and just look for hands as I say these
things after I get finished or while I'm
doing it if you
have questions along the way um you can
Brer thank you um I was just uh Dr
Warner had pretty much explained what I
had
said this exact language came from the
majority of our boards the majority of
our boards already have this exact
language um psychologists uh their
statute is a little more specific there
are a few boards that are missing this
language the the intent you know the
boards will share information with other
states to prevent Bad actors from um
Crossing Lines there are times I believe
that we've uh boards have shared
information with DHHS uh and um law
enforcement on crimes we've
unfortunately seen some pretty serious
cases that need to be reported to law
enforcement the other piece we'll need
to think about is some of our boards
have a federal requirement to um report
to the National practitioners Data Bank
so we would need to make sure that that
is able to be continued if you would
like to put some sort of conditions on
here well fortunately I don't have to
come up with the language right okay I
hope you're not not doing anything
during lunch
so do I see Miss
Courtney I know I'll
get Lindsay Courtney please yes thank
you
um and thank you for and apologize for
the delay Lindy courney executive
director office of professional
licensure um Tom and Dr Warner pretty
much uh covered what I was going to say
um but I am here for the rest of the
subcommittee meeting should you have any
questions regarding this
bill well as I said you'll be invited to
interrupt as you see fit we'll do thank
you very much representative
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman uh just a
couple of bits of information number one
is uh with regard to confidentiality
which was mentioned earlier uh there was
a subcommittee on which I sat about uh
six or seven years ago with former
representative Neil Kirk a former uh AG
uh at that time Sarah blet who became
acting executive director for a while as
some of us will
recall and it was specifically about
maintenance of confidentiality records
so if somebody complains about a
psychologist psychiatrist or a mental
health worker uh anyone across the board
in that regard there could be
confidential information that would be
gerine to the you know to the
investigation or prosecution of
misbehavior by a practitioner um and
that stuff sits around uh like ticking
time bombs in our in our records in our
fighting cabinets and so forth so but uh
Sarah might be available out there
someplace or honorable Neil clerk uh to
to talk to us about that um but that
that's an aspect that uh would be
especially sensitive uh and it was kind
of alluded to maybe not with full
recognition of the time bomb aspects of
it um but also uh especially in the
medical professions uh it certainly is
the case that there would be situations
uh where an immediate uh intervention on
the part of the the law uh is required
to to shut somebody down who's not only
a bad actor but a very significant
danger to the public uh so that that it
was referenced not today but in the
previous testimony on the bill uh those
those issues have not been addressed yet
so I have to step away but I want to I
want to congratulate everybody on this
is a very serious and productive
discussion so uh we got good people
expert people so this is going in the
right direction in my opinion
representative Schmid I'm not it's not
that I'm unconcerned with privacy I'm
just not say it seems like this is a
well-traveled well documented through
the bill I'm not going to say ouch until
they step on my foot right I I I don't I
don't I don't need to do anything except
just wave that particular issue in terms
of giving this subcommittee some
information that I am privy to having
been on the subcommittee with Sarah and
Ne Neil Kirk back in the day uh and
nobody was
else so be be advised thank you thank
you for the background thank you you're
welcome bye bye that was respect to the
psychology and mental health boards yes
and both Dr Warner and I served on that
subcommittee so the psychology board and
the mental health board have
well-crafted
privacy U protections well this bill
reflects that it does I think yes uh
this one needs a little flushing out
two yes did you just call on me yes I
think you had your hand up yes thank you
so much um yes um there are a number of
people here are new um but it was 2011
when um this came forward that the
Attorney General's office was uh taking
patients medical records without their
knowledge or consent for the use of
invest investigations and that was
concerning third party
um Associates um let's say you wanted to
investigate a pattern with a doctor and
you would requisition records that were
not part of the complaint um that went
through the governor and Council through
jail car through this committee through
the House and Senate and unanimous ly
the bipartisan everybody was against
that happening and so what resulted was
the wording that is loaded into section
in are you speaking you've cut
out and and so there are those involved
here in this process in this bill who
had never touched that that process was
worked out with representative kurk and
um Sarah blet who was representing the
Apu at that time and also your
subcommittee with uh representative
Schmidt uh representative Maguire uh
representative scitec and others and um
it was very well-crafted it was a long
process to craft that dealing with
recusal issues and all sorts of things
like that um but it was well done and
agreed to by AG's office and um the
parties uh of the the um petitioning for
the law and so if you're going to borrow
cool stuff I would hope that you might
borrow that for the other boards and um
it would be very much an enhancement I'd
be very happy to help with the revision
process and I be um I won't be
long-winded
Mr brck has been attentively listening
and will welcome the the
assistance okay uh if I may I'd like to
move on I had a little trouble with uh
Roman five allegations of professional
conduct shall be brought within five
years from the time of uh that the
office reasonably could have discovered
the ACT well you what's that mean
exactly uh it's you I would have thought
statute of limitation says five years
cut and dry it happened five six years
ago we don't look at it what's that
reasonably could have been discovered
works Mr BR Mr H
Porter thank you so I can only use an
example from a real estate uh commission
case that I had where um the the party
was unlicensed than conducting
multi-million dollar in the state and um
what we found was there were some cases
that were outside the scope of the with
with regard to the statute of
limitations um however the argument
initially was that there was no
reasonable way to find this information
but for this current investigation which
was within the statute of limitations um
ultimately the case settled and we
didn't end up litigating that but this
is this is one of those situations where
a real estate transaction may happen uh
seven years ago uh but we only find out
about it through the course of an
investigation that falls within the
statute of limitations this this allows
us to claw back to that transaction to
say there was no reasonable way we could
have discovered that but for this
ongoing investigation so it's there are
times when you have
to claw beond beyond the statute of
limitations but it's a pretty it's a
pretty high standard to show it's not
very easy to to overcome that hurdle but
it is an important hurdle uh to to
remain in there I I don't think it'll be
a practical problem but it sounds like
you call your way back forever because
if whever you find it it could be 20
years later uh that that the title is
flawed because of was an unlicensed
broker uh you can call back then because
from 20
years uh I don't think it's a practical
problem but I unless somebody else wants
to develop that just representative Bri
wants to speak okay representative
O'Brien
please thank you Mr chair uh at this
particular time if I can beg uh leave of
this committee I do have a doctor's
appointment down in Boston and it's
getting within the time for me to
disappear for that so uh I ask your
Indulgence and I will catch up with you
on uh the rest of the facts of this but
thank you representative Brian I think
we've covered the the big piece of this
there is more wordsmithing to be done
but I think you've heard the most of it
and if you want to put yourself on
speaker phone in the car you're welcome
to I'll have to ask my wife she doesn't
she doesn't share the same interest in
government that I do okay well H happy
doctor thank you sir thank you Mr BR did
you have something to say uh I was just
going to add that this language is um is
pretty standard it's already in uh 332
g91 which applies to most but not all of
oplc boards um and as Mr Porter said
there's just some instances uh think
about a uh this is used in the criminal
context too a doctor that maybe did
something negligently um but it doesn't
get discovered by the patient until s
years later um something that was put
internally incorrectly or something
along those lines um this is a way that
they can still be held viable Mr brck
even though I had said this is new law I
suspected this was boilerplate and that
I my heart really wasn't in it but I
wanted next item that I want to talk
about is Romans six the board May
dismiss a complaint if the allegations
do not State a claim of professional
misconduct what's that for that's you
know it's sort of like saying please do
sign um I'm sorry I did forgot to raise
my hand um there are times when the
boards receive complaints that do not
fit the um the qualifications of
misconduct under the statute it may be
um an angry ex spouse or a neighbor that
said
something um perhaps bad about the
person but it isn't professional
misconduct um so I think this just
making clear those cases can be
dismissed okay
um yeah it doesn't do any harm it's just
puzzling that uh let me see uh I'm
trying to read my notes here for my next
Point
um
[Music]
two line oh um yes the last line on that
page page 42 in proceedings in
accordance with procedural rules adopted
by the executive
director when I see rules and adopted I
think of jard does he uh is this
exempting uh or saying the director can
make her own rules without jaar
involvement no that should not
be do we need to add in accordance
with
541a Tom I'm sorry yes I had wanted to
say something about the previous line 30
um that our board has a very long
section about um how to dismiss a
complaint and I'm wondering if the way
this is said it's very simple and it it
won't cover all of our our issues um is
this going to override ours if this
stands as
[Music]
written uh I'm going to say that it's
not going to override it because it's
dismissals unless Mr broadrick has
something disagrees uh well I was gonna
first respond to um your previous
comment and and represented Maguire's
comment if you look at on page 41 lines
19 through 26 um this adds um to the
opl's rulemaking statute this adds that
the the executive May director May
Implement rules on hearings and
disciplinary proceedings so it
adds short answer no we don't need to
add um a statement that these rules must
go through jail car because lines
through 24 on page 41 um state that
please thank you Mr chair I just wanted
to bring up a little concern on that
language um where it says the board May
dismiss should it should it be changed
to to be specific to all boards that
boards and similar to the language which
is right below it on line 33 boards
which shall include all boards councils
and
complaint yes for symmetry I should say
so yeah that's that's uh since we since
there's going to be some changes I think
that it's let's put that in because it's
referencing just specifically the board
not stating I mean where it could be any
of the boards or commissions oh good
good
uh
next point
[Music]
please hold on just a moment this is
starting to get late I and I didn't even
Porter
um you might that's where you would say
if the complaint is unfounded yeah I let
let's get I don't think that's terribly
important um uh there was something some
[Music]
oh there is one here somewhere I gota
find it settle it the words for
settlement agreement approves by board
15 yeah settlement agreement yeah there
it is approved by the board well uh the
board's involved in the settlement
agreement how can it not be approved by
the board if there's a subcommittee on
discipline or investigatory
subcommittee that would bring they would
bring the settlement to the board Mr
um if I may I see my executive director
had her hand up may I defer to her oh
I'm sorry all right
ort me no that's okay Tom you can you
can speak um I was just going to say
that typically either the investigator
or the prosecutor will negotiate a
settlement agreement and then that's
brought to the full board um other than
the recused board member um for review
and potential
improve all right
[Music]
um
435 hold a pre uh
5A Roman 5A L 26 hold the prehearing
conferences hold preer conferences
exempt from the provisions of this is
all part of the
confidentiality yes that while they're
negotiating this stuff it's it's uh
confidential is that am I reading that
correctly that's correct okay
[Music]
uh yeah uh page 43 Romans
7 uh this concerned boards councils and
commissions may take non-disciplinary
remedial action against any person
finding that a person is Afflicted with
physical mental
disabilities
uh is there a due process there uh I
mean I realize it's not criminal but the
fact is you don't give them a chance to
advocate for themselves or say uh it's
not gas like I really am you know this
is real or something I'm not saying that
well um it seems who's making the well I
see who's making the
determination but is there a an
opportunity for the
licensed or certified person to respond
I don't see that Mr Porter is nodding
so Mr Porter um so I can defer to the
executive director I think the um and
it's a case I recently had where uh we
have to give the leny the opportunity
first to receive notice and be heard uh
before making that recommendation so we
work with or some the board's work with
the New Hampshire PHP the professional
health uh Network where we we see nurses
let say who are engaged uh let's say
drug diversion of some sort uh but there
may be an underlying condition um they
have a right to be heard before they can
be ordered potentially by the board to
uh go through an evaluation with the PHP
and then follow their recommendations so
in lie of you know going after their
license what we're trying to do is give
them an opportunity um to resolve
whatever issues may be going on in their
life at the time um and what we end up
doing in many of those instances is
entering into a settlement
agreement that is crafted you know by us
as well as with a lot of input from the
PHP because they're the mental health
experts and um so this is
really that's great you're doing a great
that's great thing to say but there's no
you don't talk about giving them notice
or an opportunity to respond here I
think the the situation is that upon
finding needs a little clarification is
there a hearing a settlement what kind
of due process is there and I'm sure
there yes so um it's it's it's actually
in the board of nursing practice act
it's the language is actually in there
um but we actually go a little further
you know due process rights are are
rights that every leny has um whether
they're spelled out in the in the U
statute it's just they have a a property
interest in their license and therefore
due process applies and that's one of
our
Hallmark portions of this is ensuring U
due process protections are afforded to
all
lenses yeah but I think I think just
adding that language after hearing I
think that would that would remedy the
subcommittee's
concerns yeah we need need a phrase
there to say what the appropriate due
process is I'd like to see more but at
goalie thank you Mr chair and I too have
a little concerned about that I
understand it may be um part of the
language in the nurse Practice Act but
um reading some of this um Afflicted
with physical mental disease disorder or
condition
um considered Dangerous by on to the
public health um we getting into medical
records or how how are we finding out
diseases and disorders of licenses and
that's that's my
concern
yes that's why we need to express what
the due process is and what the hearing
is because I mean you don't want a
dentist with Parkinson's with shaky
hands and you also don't want a nurse
I
agree moving along to uh line 10 of page
be public docket shall be retained in
accordance with the retention policy
established by the
oplc does that need U ja car can they do
that on their own the the rules
for data retention were covered in sen
Bill
58 and they will the rules will go
through jail car when they fin okay so
we
just
um
uh line 15 says any member of the board
or other person qualified to act as
presiding officer who would that
be uh you could have a former board
member you could have a hearing officer
from from the AG do they have the
authority to to uh preside once they are
appointed by the board
yes I mean as we kept explaining
designated board can't appoint anybody
designated yes yeah all right uh uh
representative Maguire has settled me
down unless someone else from op C wants
to say something or anyone
else I mean the only thing I would say
um Mr chair is that we are currently
implementing that model here in the
office we have an attorney who's an ex
hearing examiner all the boards have the
capability of um designating um that
individual to be a hearing examiner um
so this just clarifies that all boards
have that
capability uh on the same page uh line
27 disciplinary and Licensing
proceedings why is licensing there why
is it just in disciplinary because the
boards can hold hearings to consider
whether a person meets the requirements
of a license some of the boards have
rather subtle
requirements uh is that
correct yes that's correct often it
comes up in the context of it's It's
unclear based on an application whether
they meet the requirements so they'll
hold a hearing and have the leny come
forward
okay uh on line 32 on that fine thank
you on line 32 of that page approving a
settled agreement or issuing a consent
order isn't a consent order and a
thing somebody oplc I look I personally
legally look at consent orders a little
bit differently and that a settlement
agreement you're proving settlement
agreement a consent order is like an
order of the board they function as the
same so um I don't know Tom do you have
any
thoughts um not really I not really I
don't I don't know a board that has
issued a consent order to be honest that
um okay but to issue a consent order is
like insisting on voluntary compliance I
you can issue an order but issue a
consent order have they consented
they've been ordered so um I don't know
if this if this would be considered a
consent order board sometimes will
before adjudicating a case they will um
get together and Mr Porter would get
together the leny and have the licensees
sign a preliminary agreement not to
practice um and this this comes up if
the allegation against them is
particularly egregious sometimes they'll
say Okay um rather than you taking
immediate suspension of my license I
will voluntarily agree not to practice
in the interim um while this is
investigated and and heard that may be
uh an example of the consent order so we
we'll call that semi
voluntary yeah I mean they have the
they'd have the right to refuse because
they of course have due process rights
but
yes I have information on that go ahead
um a settlement agreement is is the same
process as a consent order um in that
it's negotiated and you can any
conditions at all that are legal to be
done in our statute but the cons the
settlement agreement is done prior to
the issuance of a notice of hearing once
you have a notice of hearing whatever
you come up with is then called a
consent agreement the consent
order I'm not sure I would agree with
that Dr Warner you're not it's in our
statute
maybe anyway um because it's a different
character because your settlement
agreement doesn't have a lot of
publicity until you publish it but the
consent
agreement has already had the character
of the order or or the order of
investig the notice of hearing has a lot
of the information in it and that has
been made public
I think it's just some boards use one
Porter Mr Porter you're at
that thank you so no I I just wanted to
say the consent
orders we we don't really use we don't
use them a lot but but I just want to
agree with Tom when we do a preliminary
agreement not to practice um and that
goes before the board and and the the
board chair consents to that that that's
a consent order by the board essentially
whereas a settlement agreement is
generally a f the the final stages of of
uh litigation or or the adversarial
process so um they are a little
different um but as far as settlement
agreements settlement agreements
happened before a notice of hearing is
sent out and settlement agreements do H
happen quite frequently uh once it
notice of hearing is issued so I just
Roy thank you um I was basically I I um
I actually uh was an investigator for
the Massachusetts Board of Registration
of Medicine and the Department of
Education and I was just going to
actually chime and say what he said is
that um the consent decree or consent
order is generally preliminary whereas
the settlement is a final disposition on
the case um a consent not to practice or
a consent to limit the scope of practice
things of that nature will happen while
the investigation is under way just so
that an emergency hearing to revoke the
license isn't done uh so yeah that's
just what I wanted to add that okay
thank you good um line 35 3435 says they
dispositive action taken after the
issurance of a public hearing notice
when is the public hearing notice
specified if I may I think it depends on
the board at the moment um they all have
different rules as to when the notice of
hearing must issue I think generally
it's within 10 or 14 days but it's
dependent upon the board um and
specified in the board okay okay
um
page um I don't think I had that was all
pretty straightforward very
straightforward I'm not a big fan of
putting numbers $3,000 $10,000 in
statute it's got its pluses and minuses
it uh if you say up to the discretion of
the board it can go crazy
3,000 uh life
can never mind I'm wasting your time um
on page
46 uh moving ahead uh line four prior to
imposing any sections don't you mean
sanctions yes that's a
typo I want to hear from oplc do you
agree I we
agree
I'm sorry I didn't hear you yes we agree
Mr uh now I have not I've got through
quite a few things here I hope OPC has
made a list of what we would like to
well let me here um yes there's U line
28 down here uh from 25 to 28 for the
purpose of this paragraph complaint
shall be deemed to be unfounded if it is
not fall within jurisdiction does not
relate to the actions of the ly or
determined to be frivolous what about
there is a difference between lack
sufficient Merit or evidence and
frivolous you don't you don't say just
doesn't
rise insufficient
proof it seems that's omitted should
that not be
there I think our our point was to make
clear what shall what must be considered
unfounded and to give the board
discretion to determine what else could
be considered unfounded um obviously
it's clear that frivolous complaints
must be unfounded or if they lack
jurisdiction um I think that was the
thought process behind that oh all right
so that's what the Sha okay shall be
deemed unfounded and it may be deemed
unfounded under other circumstances it
will be may be unfounded based on the
hearings and investigation right that
would be on the merits as opposed to
these which are just you're you're not
in the ballpark right right okay all
right uh one of the um things that as we
close out this fill there you have an
appeal to the Supreme Court where
wherever it is for if a hearing is
um 16 yeah uh shall be Supreme uh but
there's no the appeal on rehearing shall
be to the Supreme Court that's pretty
big deal uh what
about suppose the lyed does not
agree uh that with that uh the finding
of the board
was that he was in violation of his his
license he says no I wasn't I wanted
there is no opport opportunity re
rehearing on line 14 that says that if
you're if you've been disciplined or
you've been refused to license you can
petition for a rehear all right so
that's what that that that's the the
escape the first round first rep okay
and if and if you go through two through
the rehearing and you're still unhappy
then you go to the Supreme Court okay
all right that that addresses my concern
I did not read that well shall I
summarize where the we're hoping for
some better language uh I was looking
for very much very much for that yes
please because some of the points I made
are just information understanded others
needs correction okay so starting on
page 41 we want a clear statement that
the the board that this does not
supplant existing board uh
proceed investigatory powers and that
the boards have the authority
and the office will assign a an
investigator when the board asks them to
um I don't know exact I don't we don't
have any language that we're we're
hoping you will have some that will
explain that this is a supplemental
one all right on if I may interrupt I've
got it great we we can't lay the egg but
we can tell if it's bad
right all right on uh page 42 line to
um the executive director or the boards
are authorized to do those things um and
more
importantly section lines 18 to 20 we
need
some
restrictions and need to consider
compacts criminal Behavior Federal
requirements for reporting and things
like that um
um again this
is what's here may not be incorrect but
it's incomplete that's the main
thing about I haven't gone there yet
sorry on line 30 we want to insert which
shall include all boards councils Etc
after
board
such grammatical
change
on
um page 43 line
15 we're okay there on line
33 after line 34 after finding we need
to include a phrase the hearing or the
opportunity of hearing or due process or
whatever something to explain that the
board just hasn't made it up on their
own and the person has had a chance to
it three page with no
comments on page 46 line four the last
word is
well I think the the proper language is
elsewhere in the statutes but we'd like
it to be to be clearer here and and if
there's any of the board that have
investigatory pop or disciplinary issues
that
are totally inadequate that you feel
free to add them to the repeals on
making and did the subcommittee uh I
think we're going I we will meet again
based on when
oplc if you if op oplc Breeze uh to
draft this language when you will have
something ready for us to examine uh
call it an amendment to section seven um
uh oplc when do you think you could have
some assuming you're in agreement I
think it sounds like you are uh when do
you think we could see
something I mean I think we can
certainly get the committee something by
the end of the day tomorrow wow that's
uh that's faster than we need so yeah I
mean it this shouldn't take very long
there aren't many um changes I think
that need to be made so we can get we
can get that to you this week our
deadline for everyone's information is
May 27th to exec all the bills all the
Senate bills so
uh I think we can if you have that have
it that quickly the subcommittee will
meet sometime next week to uh to
consider it
uh let's give you uh plenty of time how
about the well we need to know what room
would be available so we have if you
want to meet
before
the uh set up Bill 58 subcommittee which
what time is which starts at 10: which
is when you get or next week yeah I can
next week I'm open oh then why don't we
plan to meet at 9ine on Thursday 9 on
Thursday
uh this
room as a sign all right I will will let
the subcommittee know does that sound
okay with oplc Thursday nine
o'clock next Thursday yes we will be
there thank you very much okay thank you
thank you for your help your cooperation
yes Dr Warner you twoo thank you all
right representative Shu did you have
anything to
say
well okay she didn't uh take care and uh
we're
adjourned sorry I was trying to find my
unmute thank you well okay H here's your
chance go no I I didn't have anything to
add I was mainly just trying to um
Monitor and and
learn terrific thank you thank you for
being here okay uh good morning we'll
see you all later yes the uh the other
subcommittee on uh the compact is
starting at 1
so yes we'll have uh two indiv I think
myself and Tina Kelly will be there I'd
be I'd be happy to look at what you come
up with um Lindsay and and know if you
could send it to me I'd appreciate it
you
[Music]
anything
Me anybody okay thank
you I was testing my headphones I know
I'm not in this I just was kind of
observing oh absolutely I just saw your
name so I uh clicked on it to test my
audio and uh Terry um since I used your
link I'm showing up with the name of uh
Terry Roy yeah that's what I was afraid
of but that's okay we know who you are
I'll fix it I'll fix it it's fine he
didn't get a link Pam that's why oh I
sent them they went out um before the
first meeting this morning so they went
out at 9:00 this morning and they went
out yesterday afternoon oh okay so I I'm
sorry I just saw that it may have been
buried under other stuff and I was
expecting it as usual an hour before so
yeah this was all sort of like one long
meeting from this morning yeah plus we
we that oh I got the link for the 10: am
meeting I thought that couldn't be used
for this oh no it's the same link yeah
I'm sorry about that I'm GNA drop out
and use that link I'll be back in
shortly okay actually not there's no
reason to I
guess your name is
um correct all right I don't know if
anybody is going to be in the room or
not I don't know
either Carol maybe she was there this
morning it's
great um I got an email from
representative Schultz saying she could
not make it and she wanted to have
representative Schmidt or
replacer um I'm not sure if he's on here
or
not I don't see him oh let me make you a
sorry if um if he's not here in the next
minute perhaps representative goalie
would be kind enough to fill in for
representative
Schultz I could do that Mr chair thank
um let me see who else is supposed to be
on this me
Tony Jeff will be there for Kristen and
who else am I missing uh representative
groda and representative lanzara are the
other that's right y we'll give them
two
do we have anybody
um who's not a representative anybody
from uh oplc or anything on here yeah I
see we have nine attendees and Tom
bradrick is there okay Tina Kelly is
here from
oplc okay representative lonar is there
so we're just waiting for representive
groda oh there she is okay oh excellent
excellent all right so um we're just
going to have uh representative goalie
take fill in for represent um
Schultz great all right I'm gonna start
the subcommittee meeting
script go ahead what I was just gonna
say I'll hit record I I was spacing that
out so okay are you ready I am ready go
ahead covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing on this particular bill that was
referred to the committee and
subcommittee and scheduled in the
calendar for today and executive session
uh may be held on any bill this there
won't be one please note that there is
no physical location for members of the
public to observe or listen
contempor contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order I am confirming that all
members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen and
if necessary participate in this meeting
by Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
RSA 91 Dasa anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 603
3600 or email
HCS
l.
state. n. Us in the event the public is
unable to access this meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled please note that all votes
are taken during this meeting shall be
done by roll call vote start the meeting
by taking attendance each member State
their presence and please also state
where whether there's anyone in the room
with you during the meeting which is
law
so representative
leus I'm present at home and my wife may
be in and out
representative
groa I'm present in my home office and
I'm
alone representative
lanzara hi I am uh on the way home right
now mobile and
alone
representative um
goalie I am at home and my wife is in
the other
you representative leus is kind enough
to take the minutes for the meeting
today
and we will
begin um has anyone on the subcommittee
had a chance to look at this bill and
anything they'd like to start off the
discussion
with um if I could
absolutely so yeah I went through this
and took some notes on it and um you
know it it proposes that we join two uh
separate seate interstate compacts one
dealing with Audiology and speech
pathologists and the other one with uh
occupational therapy and uh the reason I
was asking if there's somebody from oplc
on is um my first question is how we
deal with this I mean what happens if we
want to make any changes to it um you
know what's the process after that I
mean you know who who actually wrote
this up um how any and which states if
any are actually part of this compact
already because uh according to it it
comes into effect when uh the 10th State
joins um and if you know is it in effect
now in 10 10 or more
States um you know just general
questions kind of guide us into what
we're going to do I mean if we if we
make any changes and it's going to
require you know let's say there's 10
other states involved and 10 other
states would have to de decide to agree
to it um you know then in effect are we
going to be killing the thing um yeah so
general questions around that why don't
we let uh why don't we let uh Tina Kelly
go ahead and give us a short um synopsis
and start off from there Miss Kelly good
morning members of the
subcommittee I'm Tina Kelly and um the
language that's in the law the way it
sits right now that was worked on by the
Council of state governments there is a
organization that they contract with
they've done the physical therapy
contract compact they were did the
nursing compact so the the development
of this compact was done
um through the Council of state
governments who who has very a lot of
experience putting this
together um changing the wording of what
is going forward in the
bill if it changes the meaning of
anything I and I'm G to ask Tom to jump
in here if if I'm stating any of this
wrong but if you change that then we
can't go ahead with the the the
legislation because it won't match up
with what the other states are doing as
far as how many states are involved at
the present time I do not know there may
be somebody from one of the associations
that knows how many States presently
belong to the
compact okay so um in rep response to
representative lexus's question the
wording as it stands in this proposed
bill is exactly what it has to be to
match up to what the other states have
agreed to to be in the compact is that
what I'm hearing that is correct because
if we change it we won't match up with
them and it won't
work okay um have we passed any other
legislation similar to this that's
already gone
through yes the one that I'm very very
familiar with is the physical therapy
compact it pretty much is it's so
closely mirrors this um and that's been
effect for four years now I think about
there and I've been involved in that
since before it started right through
getting it through legislation and the
implementation of it we run into any
issues with this um it worked very well
it allowed um it allows people to go and
come and even though we're not we don't
have a lot of surrounding states that
belong to that we do have um people come
in temp when temporary workers are
needed to fill in I mean it's it's been
really good for the
businesses I is this um we went over
kind of in depth the one uh related to
um
EMTs is this um similar exactly the same
the compact structure
Etc I don't know what the EMT one looks
like I don't really work with that with
them at um the one that I can say that I
know about is the pt1 that's been in
effect that is very similar to this okay
question well I'm hoping I can help I um
have a I I can send everyone this this
is a link I'm reading from the
um the Senate uh hearing that was and
the person who wrote the compact the
legal council from CSG Nal calus spoke
at the Senate hearing and what she said
was that they were the primary uh draft
drafter of the
compact um that
um they would use a mutual recognition
model like a driver driver's
license and that um Asha took a primary
role in crafting the
compact um then they ALS Senator Carson
had asked what other states were
involved in the
Compact and they are North Carolina
Louisiana Utah West Virginia and
Wyoming and it's being considered in 13
more and I just interject a little bit
I'm sorry to interrupt you but I I I
just pulled up the Audiology and speech
language pathology interstate compact
website yeah and they they list as of
April 2021 10 states the States you
mentioned but a few more so I don't know
just just to say that and I could list
them off to you but that's that's what
their website indicates information
about the compact thank you I I can send
this link to everybody on the
subcommittee because I thought it was
very interesting interesting um the
information because there are people
that testified at this hearing that
didn't testify at all okay very good
thank you that would be helpful uh
representative
leus uh thank you Mr chair uh I actually
have a question for uh Miss Kelly and um
you mentioned we've been in uh the PT
compact one thing I saw on here is the
commission has the authority to uh to do
rulemaking
and um those go in you know there's
public hearings and all that but those
go into effect unless a majority of the
state legislators I guess oppose them my
question is any rules that these uh
commissions create how do they interact
with the way New Hampshire normally
handles rul making in that uh you know
they'd have to go before Jael cars um
and then there'd be an opportunity there
if Jael cars objects to uh to do
something about it thank you this this
these rules that would be um the bylaws
and the rules of the compact commission
would not go through jlc car they do
they have their own rul making um
process which is described in here but
it's basically the only rules that they
are
um are writing would be rules and bylaws
that govern the compact itself and how
followup if I could yeah absolutely go
ahead so um you know I hope it wouldn't
be an issue but if uh you know New
Hampshire did object to any of these the
uh you know somebody I guess would have
to would they have to do what introduce
a a resolution saying we object or how
would it work short of withdrawing from
the whole thing I I believe that is
that's ex um explained in the compact I
was looking over I'm not like an expert
on everything in there but under Section
10 is it outlines the rule making
process for the compact
commission yeah I looked I looked at
that
um so yeah my concern is I mean this is
this would put in place rules that
would you know affect New Hampshire and
uh and certainly audiologists and
uh well
wouldn't affect it wouldn't affect the
practice of that audiologist in New
Hampshire it would affect their ability
to become part of the compact go from
one compact state to another um the
rules would set up dispute resolutions
between two
states if there were two Li a
lcy
um rules on their the database they're
developing thing so it's it's more
concentrated on the compact commission
than it is the practice of the liccy in
the state of New
Hampshire um I have a question if if we
join the compact does that prohibit us
from adjusting our scope and rules of
practice going forward in other words if
we do something to change how we um deal
with or conduct licensing in this field
would that automatically kick us out of
the compact would it put us in violation
of the agreement in other words is the
legislator's hands going to be tied
forever because we're in the compact so
that we can't make any
adjustments no we can do rule making to
the rules of the State of New Hampshire
at any time we want we don't have to ask
permission for the compact we don't have
to get their approval the only caveat to
that would be there's a minimum set of
criter criteria that somebody needs to
have in order to be a compact member
that would be everybody's agreed that
the and it's and it's pretty uniform for
these practices anyways that the
education should be um for speech
language pathology Audiology the
examination should be um the national
exam there should be a background check
and there should be a certain level of
continuing education and that is the
minimum standard those are the pretty
much the things that you wouldn't be
able to
change to lessen you could make them
more stringent but you couldn't lessen
them or then you would be in violation
of the compact but there isn't many of
those things it's just a
baseline for um the qualifications of a
licy okay representative
goalie thank you Mr chair uh just a
couple quick questions because I want to
go back to some of the questioning I had
on these compacts um during the public
hearing and I guess my first question is
while CSG is doing the boilerplate
language was this originally intended I
think part of the hearing public hearing
we heard was uh it was brought to csg's
attention for military families to
alleviate uh some of the issues they
have uh moving from Base to Base with
about
um and that's my question first question
was the intent of this legislation the
original compacts for
military and
family I am not sure if that was the
original attent um
intent it's my what I've always heard
and what the benefit is to the military
there's a big benefit to Military and
military families but this was intended
to
facilitate um individuals being able to
travel easily between states with how
without having to keep doing the same
thing over and over again submitting
their transcripts submitting a proof of
exam to help facilitate that ease of
Mobility for all like people who are in
this profession who are
licensed follow up yes go ahead thank
you uh one of the other concerns and
this is what
kind of puts my cold feet to this
compact deal is when we start looking at
we hear mobility and traveling and
moving from state to state um if we get
an influx
of licensed individuals from other
states coming to New Hampshire to work
under other states
licensing um and there's investigations
of whatever kind it may be on any one of
these
individuals um and this is where I want
to hear from op PLC um are we in charge
of the investigation if it is brought
forward under someone who is from
another state licensed under another
state say whether it's Louisiana um
someone travels up here a complaint is
filed against that individual who heads
up that in investigation and uh where
does it go from there I want full
details on how this will work it depends
on where that patient or client is
located if the patient or client is
located in the state of New Hampshire we
would open a full
investigation um I believe and I'm
trying to see in here if it says it that
I it's my understanding is that once an
investigation is opened the compact
commission would be
notified and so we couldn't take any
action against the person's license we
would take the action against the
person's privileged to practice in the
state of New
Hampshire if the allegations were found
founded we would take away their
privilege to practice they would lose
all their privileges to practices
practice in all the other states and
then the home state would take action
against the
ahead so through due process
if this investigation goes back to the
home state and say the home State's
Louisiana uh witnesses to this that need
to be brought forward for the public
hearing do they need to travel to
Louisiana representative goalie I think
I think what she said was that the
investigation would occur in New
Hampshire and we would take action
against their right to practice in the
Hampshire and the results of that would
be referred to their home state for
further action if that's what I was
hearing correctly was that correct Miss
Kelly that's
correct but is not the true hearing on
the individual's license being done
in their home
state on their on their license they
would take action in their home state on
yes so does a person go before their
home state for a hearing for that
license
revocation if that was what it was or a
reciprocal action most of the time
doesn't end up in revocation it may end
up in a sanction against the license
continuing educ ation finds whatever and
they could take reciprocal
action is is is can you find out if
there's ever been a a case I'd like to
see a real world example of this in
practice has there been a case where
somebody in the compact has been
investigated and and action taken
against them in the visiting State and
then what happened when it was referred
back to their home state I because I I
agree with representative goalie I I'd
like to see the the the mechanics of how
this would work because someone has a
property vested property right right in
their license so they would be entitled
to a a due process hearing in their
state and I don't know if what we
investigate and do in the Hampshire
would uh would adequately fulfill that
Mr bradrick could you perhaps answer
that
question yes uh and thank you
representative Roy and um I I believe I
can so I I think of them differently you
have your home state license and your
privilege to practice the allows you you
can I can be here in New Hampshire if I
am in a if this compact passed I could
be here in New Hampshire and I could
just have a New Hampshire license still
and then I would be um only able to
practice here in New Hampshire if I I
then joined the compact if I then got my
privilege to practice through the
compact it's almost like I hold a
separate license that allows me to go to
another state that that's what would be
taken away um so representative goalie
to your example someone um a speech
language pathologist is doing work in
New Hampshire who's originally licensed
in Louisiana if they commit misconduct
here in New Hampshire our board can take
action against their privilege to
practice through it would they' still
have a hearing they'd have a notice of
the charges against then they' have a
hearing at the end of that hearing our
board could decide to revoke their
privilege to practice here in New
Hampshire so they couldn't practice here
in New Hampshire um our public are
protected in addition um I'd have to
find where it says this but once we
revoke their privilege to practice uh
notification gets sent to the compact um
and I don't remember if the compact
automatically revokes their privileged
practice in any other state or or I'd
have to
look into that but we we still are able
to protect our own citizens does that
but what happens what happens to their
actual license from their home state in
other words so okay we refer it the
contact revokes their right to be a
member of the
compact then the I'm assuming the whole
matter would be referred to the home
state well now the home state wants to
take action do they have to have a whole
other due process hearing where they
won't be ble to produce New Hampshire
Witnesses or all that or they can they
rely simply on the record of the New
Hampshire
proceeding it it probably depends on the
home States uh Practice Act there I
would tell you in New Hampshire that
someone would have I believe they'd have
to have a whole another that if the
reverse it was a new New Hampshire
practitioner that committed misconduct
in Louisiana had their life their
privilege to practice taken away if the
New Hampshire board then caught wind of
it and said we want to revoke New
Hampshire license um I believe we'd have
to hold another hearing I do see um and
I'm not trying to pass the buck Susan
Adams from Asha who helped draft this
legislation or her her group did so if
I'm misspeaking Susan please let me know
no I think you're I think you're right
on target um like you said New Hampshire
only has the right to revoke the
privilege to practice in that state and
once that privilege is revoked the home
state can choose or not um to have a due
process hearing to revoke their license
depending on what kind of bad action
they they had in New Hampshire um some
states you know the kind of the joke
that we had when we were um working on
this compact was marijuana marijuana is
legal in some states not legal in other
states so if your bad action um was to
partake in marijuana and your home state
doesn't that isn't illegal in your home
state then your home state probably
wouldn't take action against your your
state license so it's really up to the
home state to decide whether or not that
action has reached a level to where they
would contemplate removing your state
license and then once your state license
is removed you you lose all of your
state representative
Shu or representative goalie were you
done no that still doesn't answer my
question if the home state has a hearing
do the witnesses have to travel from
state to state for that hearing so let
me let me um put it like this I mean
because we heard from Mr brck that New
Hampshire would have a whole another
hearing if it was something that took
place in Louisiana with a New Hampshire
license holder so when that hearing
taking place here in New Hampshire do
the witnesses have to be
present so that that really is up to the
the the state that's holding the
investigation or hearing but what I will
say that basically this is the same as
somebody has a license here and they
also have a just a license in Louisiana
and we take action against that license
we would send it on to Louisiana and
then their law and rules would kick in
and they would do what they needed to do
in that situation they could hold a
hearing they may not it's it's up to
them am
I I'm not sure if New Hampshire does
this but I know that many states have as
a condition of lure that if your right
to practice in another state is revoked
it's similarly revoked in the state that
you got the license so I'm not sure that
if a a duplicate due process hearing
would be necessary or not um if anyone
could speak to that um I think I can and
I think this will enter um
representative Go's question um
it if I was Prosecuting the case for the
New Hampshire board um and a someone had
had their a New Hampshire Home State
lensey who was practicing in in
Louisiana and had their privilege to
practice there revoked by Louisiana my
number one exhibit would be here's the
order of Louisiana revoking their
privilege to practice um that would
probably be enough to pass the uh burden
of appr here in New Hampshire 51% that
they did something wrong and um their
license should be revoked if I want to
be extra careful and I can get that um a
witness to what happened in Louisiana
available to testify via Zoom I would do
that but I think you would be using the
exhibit of what
Louisiana of Louisiana's action is of
proof that it occurred and the reason
that we'd be taking away the license as
long as Louisiana an offered a a hearing
that provided the same substantial due
process rights as in Hampshire I would
think that judicial notice of the
previous hearing they wouldn't have to
redo it over again just because it's in
a different geography is that
correct um we would
uh we wouldn't have to have a whole
hearing
over they would be they do have a due
process right in their home state
license because we'd be taking action
against a different license so we would
have to provide notice to them and the
opportunity for a hearing um they might
it would be it wouldn't be as large of a
hearing for that very reason that it's
already the underlying issues have
already been um dealt with in Louisiana
and we could use that Louisiana court
order or not court order sorry board
order is our proof um but there would
still be a a brief hearing here in New
Hampshire okay thank you if I could um
yeah um yeah some of this I think is
addressed if if you look at page 10
starting at line 24 section 7 adverse
actions it deals with
um you know what what the U member State
the remote State can do and this is um
around the privilege to practice and
their right to have practice as part of
the compact rather than H State one and
I could see there being concerns because
the practitioner may be remote and other
information that we would want in New
Hampshire is remote and it does say that
um you know we could issue subpoenas for
both hearings and investigations
requiring attendance testimony
Witnesses um we'd have to pay to get
people here but it does say you know we
could uh recover those costs from the uh
person the action was being taken
against so anyway there is some language
in here uh dealing with that and also
with joint
investigations okay thank you uh
representative Shu um you're not on the
subcommittee so if you could just say
where you are and you know the 91a stuff
please before you sure thank you yes I'm
um zooming in from my home in Pembrook
and I am
alone um I just wanted to point out that
um well first of all I'll just comment
the thought occurred to me that um
talking about testifying for a hearing
uh New Hampshire is pretty used to using
Zoom but I would point out that many
states particularly Southern stat such
as Louisiana have been more demanding
about uh people attending in person so I
think we might have some conflicts with
uh trying to make our case via the
Internet what I was originally going to
say though I heard Miss Kelly talking
about uh each state in the compact would
be basically able to make their own
rules and serving as a member of JAL car
I will point out that New Hampshire is
pretty well known as being um the most
legislative active regarding our
administrative rules process uh we have
more legislative input in that process
than any other state in the US I believe
that's my understanding so if other
states are making their own rules uh
that seems like it could be atic in
regards to how the compact is treated by
each state um I just wanted to point
that out thank you I I just if I could I
would say that the from my reading of
the bill it says the the rule making
Authority pertains only to the compact
itself not to the scope or extent of
practice within the state so we would
still have authority over how the rules
are made for with everything that
happens within our state the the rul
making Authority for this would only
apply to um uh how we interact in the
compact um uh representative grto you've
had your hand up for a
while thank you that's exactly what I
was goingon to say I think that if we if
we use the the license let's use the
driver license analogy you know um these
audiologists would have a license
similar to a driver's license that was
actually issued by the
compact and then my concern is if
somebody does something in a state
there's a couple of concerns I have
number one these states and these
compacts are very far away and you know
is there
um are do have we entered in these in
compacts with states that are this far
from our our own State um number two um
we would have to be very involved with
the rul making of the compact
itself and um do we have the I mean do
we have that ability to put some um
language in through this legislation or
through other
ways so that we know that New
Hampshire's residents are protected and
our state is protected for example if
somebody does something
in um a state other than their home
state and um there's an issue like let's
say they have a license in um North
Carolina and something happens in
Mississippi how do we know how is that
communicated is that it's going to be
Comm communicated I guess through the
compact right and then with the compact
even though it's sort of like the the
what happens to that license C is within
their own state
regulations um how would that if do we
have the right to revoke a license from
someone who's been who's lost their
license in another state or is that the
job of the
compact I think we already have that
even if we don't join the compat uh
Senator Sherman thank you go ahead yeah
I just want to um thank you for letting
me join uh I just wanted to answer some
of Jackie's I'm sorry representative
grot concerns first of all the person is
not licensed by the compact they're
licensed by their home
state uh and so when you think about the
way things work right now um I have um
one active license but at one point I
had four active licenses I had uh New
Hampshire uh actually three New
Hampshire Virginia and
Massachusetts and and Tom is absolutely
right if something if I were
sanctioned at all in any of those States
all states would know about it and I'm
required to report it just like I'm
required to report any malpractice or
any other
infraction um so in a way the compact
actually gives an
internal uh conduit for information
where um say for example someone is
practicing in New Hampshire under the
Compact and their home is down in
Louisiana the compact actually will make
sure that anything that happens in New
Hampshire is is known in
Louisiana and um so it's in in a way it
actually protects New Hampshire
residents more while decreasing the
regulatory burden and cost on the
lensey uh and I and I think the other
I'm was trying to remember the earlier
point I think that representative goalie
was or the question that he was asking
asking this really doesn't change much
in the way of what would happen if my
license in New Hampshire if I lost my
license in New Hampshire and I had a
license in Virginia Virginia would look
at what happened in New Hampshire would
make a decision if they felt they needed
Witnesses they could call witnesses from
New Hampshire but they're not compelled
to and it's really the that I agree with
completely the I have seen Physicians
who have lost licenses in one State lose
their licenses in other states because
of the nature of the infraction that
occurred in that one state so we're not
Reinventing the wheel here these
compacts we have them in nursing already
and we've had them for several years
they work really well and one of the one
of the huge impacts is that it actually
decreases the cost of being a
professional in New Hampshire
um by decreasing the need to relicense
in multiple
States um so I think I hope Jackie I've
answered your
questions um but remember this is this
is something that right now is actually
more
burdensome because you are licensed in
multiple States than being a part of a
connected conduit of information with a
license in one
state Senator Sheran if you could um is
this similar to the
EMT compact that we discussed earlier in
so far as someone utilizing it um it's
it's on a temporary you know basis it's
not you know you can't just come here
and live here and operate under the
compact um you'd be required to get a
license at some point in New Hampshire
is that not true no that's that's not
the case so compact nursing uh right now
I mean the beauty of it is if if you
have
a um suppose I think Maine is looking at
this suppose Maine enters into this if
it right now if you're a nurse a compact
nurse and your license is in Maine and
you have a job uh you live in Maine but
you have a job in New Hampshire you can
come over to New Hampshire you don't
have to have a
license uh and in in virtually all
aspects of health care right now we are
deficient in our
Workforce um and so this has really been
seen as something that makes it uh
attractive to practice in New Hampshire
because you don't have to have a license
in New Hampshire if you have if you're
part of the if New Hampshire is a part
of the compact so it's different but
it's different for very important reason
which is is that we we need to have
people able to be nimble in where they
practice uh and these are not high
necessarily highly
reimbursing um professions and so you
know $120 or whatever the fee is Tom
would know better than I would but
whatever that fee is um is is something
that um is saved in every state so if
somebody lived in Maine and practiced in
New Hampshire and Massachusetts and they
were part of a compact that spanned all
three states they would only need to be
licensed in one state but they would
have the same level of screen in in all
three states as they would as if they
were licensed in all three
states and the interconnectivity of the
compact actually
increases the communication between the
states on their performance and
competencies what about uh just a second
Tony what about off offsetting in other
words so if you currently you have to
have a license in whatever state you so
like yourself you said you had several
licenses used to keep active there was a
fee Associated that and that fee went to
the organization that had the
responsibility to oversee and and police
if you will the the practice in that
state if if we have people getting a
license in one State Kansas for example
and they come and they're practicing
here and their license expires and they
just keep renewing it in Kansas well
Kansas is getting the money but we're
we're picking up the duty to to police
them and to to um manage that practice
in this state is that not the case or in
other words are we are we losing ref
Revenue that that a lot of our boards
are require to maintain their own
function right well the boards are
self-funding as you said and U that's
that's a good question might be better
for Tom to answer the fiscal side of
that or or somebody from oplc to answer
how that's handled um Senator Sherman I
can I can address that question the
states have the ability to assess a fee
to each person that they um issue a
privilege to practice to and that's
specifically to make up any lost revenue
from um you know from having previously
required that person to get a a full
license and is that in the language of
the
statute yep and I would also mention
your
um your example of somebody in Kansas uh
you know who keeps renewing their
license in Kansas if you have physically
moved and your state of residence is now
New Hampshire you are required to get a
a home state license in New Hampshire so
okay that seemed to contradict what
Senator Sherman had said where it's
where you're basically where you hold
your driver's license where you pay your
taxes um you have to have that home
state license in order to access the
compact
okay I must I think I misunderstood the
question but that's correct what Susan
said okay thank you representative leus
thank you Mr chair um yeah that's one
point I was going to make that uh if you
move here um you do have to get a lition
is for the military uh families that
they can have declare their state of
residence and they don't have to change
it even if they're you know on duty here
let's say for a couple of years they can
still maintain their home license and
their family could uh that's one here
thing here that's explicitly for the
military um the other thing is it's a
lot like a driver's license one is if
you move to another state you have to
get a new driver's license
and also if you look at page 10 at the
top um let's say you've got a license in
Louisiana but you're practicing in New
Hampshire um you have to follow the
rules in New
Hampshire um you know even though your
license is this compact license that
you're using same thing as if you drive
in another state I mean they'll accept
your driver's license but you have to
follow their rules
there yeah that's that's good
representative
goalie
thank you Mr chair and I I had the same
concerns you did about uh Revenue um
with the number of folks coming in here
um and with the licensing fees that we
could possibly lose um because at first
it sounded like they could shop around
for probably the cheapest license fee
and go to that state and then just come
back here to New Hampshire to practice
for a little while and move on somewhere
else um is my concern but I think in
hearing this
um we ought to put something in and we
look further into these compacts that if
we are going to have people coming into
New Hampshire who are part of the
compact I think they should be charged
the fee I don't know if they are now I
don't believe they are but we need to
look into that and I think it needs to
be done let me um give you an example of
the fee that a fee that is charged the
PT board has basically the same thing so
what they did is they looked at what the
compact commission was charging was I I
believe they were
charging
$50 and so the PT board said okay
they're paying $50 to the compact
they're going to pay New Hampshire for
their privileged
$6 we don't have as much paperwork to do
and we don't have as much of that type
of thing to do so we charged less for
the privilege but we're still getting
that revenue for every time they renew
their license they have to renew their
compact privilege so every two years
just like everybody else so if anything
happens there's that money coming in to
cover some of those costs is that um how
is that fee established is that
established through room making um who
who sets the fee what's the process for
that that we set it in rule making so is
that rule uh compact rule making or is
that regular rul making that the
legislature would have oversight through
jail car I believe because I think I did
it it was through jail car and it was
set within the PT board's New Hampshire
rules okay and one followup Mr chair yes
please um I noticed in this bill and the
language of the compact um
there's uh cost associated with this
organization and um the ability to
collect fees to help pay for the costs
um I'd like to hear a little more about
how that is taken care of and what the
structure
I was going to defer to Susan I can try
to answer that um so the the the compact
commission does have the ability to
assess states of fee to be part of the
Compact and that's to help fund the work
of the commission itself um and creating
that database maintaining all the
information um covering comp uh
commission meetings there's like a
yearly commission meeting um so the
compact does have the ability to assess
that fee but what that fee is and if
there will be an assessment is really up
to the compact commission um I know that
for this compact we've we've already
talked about looking at Grants um that
we could possibly get to help fund You
Know cover a lot of those costs so that
we wouldn't have to assess the states um
so those are things you know we would
look at you know federal grants DOD now
has a grant um to help fund compacts um
so we would be looking at things like
that I know that I believe it's the
nursing compact does
not assess States and I think that the
and Tina correct me if I'm wrong I think
that the PT compact does assess States
now not that I know of I don't think
that there's no they aren't assessing
they're going on what they're making off
of the the compact privileges okay yeah
so I think it's you know right now I
don't know that any states then are
actually
assessing um or any compacts are
assessing States let's assume that they
did though let's assume that because we
they have the authority to they assess a
feat in the Hampshire where did those
funds come from um and and how would
they be
appropriated I think that would just be
up to the to to you guys to decide who
would pay that fund you know would it
come out from a general a g general fund
would it come from the board specific Al
I think different states handle it
differently um so it would it would
depend on how you guys want to handle
that it just seems a little difficult
for for the legislature to say that
we're it's basically a blank check um
because they can set whatever they want
and then we have to find a way to fund
it later on that's a little concerning
um Mr bradrick you had your hand up well
I was just gonna add that so um op PLC
boards there are four boards that belong
to compacts uh PT I think medicine
um psychology and one other nursing
obviously um if the subcommittee would
like I'm happy to go back to our finance
person and figure out if any of them are
charging and how much it's being charged
right now I'll also just point out that
oplc is self-funded um so we don't get
funds from the general fund um if I
would imagine if
uh we started getting charged a fee from
a compact commission we could Implement
rules similar to what Tina had said and
charge the people coming in to get the
privilege to practice um a fee that
would cover the compact commission fee
um that's just one way it could be done
but yeah I wanted to point out the money
wouldn't be coming from the general fund
it's opl's
self-funded I I agree that oplc self
funded but this statute doesn't seem to
say that the money is going to come from
oplc so so that it kind of leaves it up
in the air where the money is going to
come from which would only leaves the
general fund um and since we have no
idea what that fee is um you know is it
$1,000 is it $50,000 I mean it's
um seem to rec call that nursing might
charge
$6,000 and per state per state but and
and we've had you know I've had talks
about this with with CSG you know and
granted it's not in writing anywhere but
I we would not be able to charge more
than nursing charges as just a matter of
Common Sense almost um you know nursing
is the biggest compact out there they
have the most members um it would not do
be good for us and it wouldn't be good
for states to charge more than what they
would
charge go ahead Senator I I I would be
absolutely open to an amendment that
that put the responsibility for handling
those charges on oplc so that you know
so that it is self-funded it's not
impacting the general
fund I I appreciate that I was actually
about to suggest that I think that's a
good idea I think that other states have
done that just so that we're not tying
future legislators to a bill that we
don't know what it
goalie thank you Mr chair um and I just
um
page 12 um gives what the uh some of the
things the commission can do U if you go
down from page 12 to page
13 um some of the things that go
forward purchase and maintain insurance
bonds borrow accept and Contract
Services of personnel including but not
limited to employees of a member State
hire employees elector appoint officers
on and on and on um sell and convey
mortgages pledge lease exchange
abandoned otherwise dispose of any
property real personal or mixed
establish a budget make expenditures
borrow money um there's a whole lot of
things that these folks can do and it
kind
of puts a little makes you step back a
little bit wondering um with all these
things they can do um who's overseeing I
know the commission board commission Who
was appointed uh overseeing
but um looking at the budget and uh the
states that are going to be paying who's
going to be actually be overseeing this
ense representative goalie I would
mention that that is actually standard
language it's in the nursing Compact and
the PT compact um as for who will be
overseeing the whole thing the the
compact commission um so every state who
is a member of the compact will have two
members
um represent their state one audiologist
and one speech language pathologist and
they they will be the ones who will make
all of the decisions um there will be an
executive committee that will be uh
voted into existence by those compact uh
Commissioners um just to see to the
day-to-day operations of the compact but
it is it is really uh an instrumentality
of the state the compact commission is
really an instrumentality of the state
um and every all the decisions will be
follow are they going to have a
centralized office for these folks going
to be from their home States and working
via zoom and holding meetings that way
or how do that take place I mean in the
beginning it's probably going to be a
volunteer position uh to take over I
know that the nursing commission uh just
got their first real employee that they
pay um within the last couple of years
so in the beginning it's just going to
be volunte
work of you know between the states and
and the organizations that have um a
stake in the in the commission um there
won't be a paid position overseeing the
compact there won't be office space
anything like
that um if I just Mr chair that and
that's one of my concerns we're hearing
the nursing compact has just got their
first employee and are we starting
something that's just going to grow and
cost money um as we go forward and more
States on board and it gets bigger and
bigger that it it's just going to be
expanding that's my concern I hope that
it expands I mean we we want it to be a
50-state compact um nursing right now I
believe is at 34 states um but again
they have there are four million nurses
in the country um they're one of the
biggest occupations in this country we
have you know Asha ourselves have only
218,000 members um so it's it's only
going to be able to get so big um but I
think you know once more States join
then we you know maybe have a the
ability to to pull funds a little bit
more to be able to afford those things
it may be that the the this compact
never has a a you know a paid employee
that oversees it it might be done
entirely by the executive committee um
it just really depends on how like you
said how big it gets um but I I can't
see us as being big enough
to operate in the way that the nursing
compact operates I am I I I like the
concept the whole concept of the compact
think I think is great I just as
stewards of the taxpayer funds we have
to be really careful that we don't have
one person whoever that may be who is
the New Hampshire representative on the
committee for the compact able to commit
the state of New Hampshire um to
expenses in other words um it says they
can take out loans um I don't personally
think that there should be one person
speaking for the State of New Hampshire
saying yeah go ahead we approve of that
loan um there's got to be some kind of
firewall to protect the taxpayers from
being committed to something um without
at least legislative oversight on some
level I I I'd hate to see us getting a
bill in the mail for something that was
agreed to by one person that we granted
this authority
to well and I don't think that that
those people the the Commissioners are
not going to have a blank check I mean
they're they're only going to be able to
do what oplc tells them that they're
going to be able to do ultimately oplc
will be
overseeing what goes on with the
commission and what those Commissioners
are allowed to do or say I I would agree
with you because they're a
representative they're not a sole
individual acting on their own they're a
representative of the state and of the
board and they would before they would
do anything like that they would have to
come back and get a they can't just act
unilaterally they'd get permission
they'd run it by the board just like any
other thing that they do and you can
Tom could I say something oh go ahead
Tom go ahead I'm sorry I was just gonna
say I think you're right Tina and I if
this would work I I would want to make
sure this wouldn't blow up the compacts
I I think it wouldn't but as we
discussed earlier may be room for some
sort of amendment saying the funds have
to come from the oplc general fund and
maybe it could also say something like
which those funds or the the fees we
take in to issue these Interstate
licenses have to cover those fees so
we're not so we're not charging anyone
in the state we're not charging New
Hampshire only lies we're charging the
people that are taking advantage of the
compact I I don't know if that's
possible um I
guess I know that we can't Tinker too
much with the language of the compact or
else it um it doesn't work with the
other states I don't know if we can add
funding language if we can I could bring
it back to my executive director and see
if she would agree and I can bring
something back to the committee well I I
as far as I'm concerned I mean the
language of the compact has to be what
it is but there can be a higher level uh
wording that says that you know anything
uh they the compact Representatives
can't commit to anything on behalf of
the state without approval of of
somebody do you follow what I'm saying I
don't want to mess with the language
necessary to be in the compact but I
want to fail safe or some type of
firewall that says okay before anything
is committed to um financially on behalf
of the State of New Hampshire that
there's at least more approval than than
even than
OPC representative leus go ahead I'm
sorry
thank you I mean next because I yeah she
did have her hand up okay I'm sorry go
ahead go ahead Jackie I'm sorry I'm just
trying to Neal out what the issues are
because between all of us I think that
if we look at we understand how we
license within our
state right so and and that we feel very
comfortable because we feel we have
control over that the licensing fees pay
for the um the the uh operation of the
committee of the board is that right yes
there's no and so the issue that I think
the that what we're trying to understand
is um and then and we already have had
legislation that as a policy has allowed
us to have con compacts in four
other practices
correct and why are we so I'm asking
myself why is it that now how is this
compact different from the other
ones and what can you tell us about
these
compacts that
will um answer the question on our in
our mind about how this is if we know
for example that this compact is going
to work similarly to the other
ones is it drastically different is it
identical is it similar I think this is
the thing that we need to because we've
we've entered in compacts before so how
is this compact different from other
compacts and do the other compacts have
we incurred fees you know have we
incurred costs for those compacts and if
so how what were they
addressed well I can say that this these
two compacts were modeled after the the
PT compact they are I wouldn't say
they're exact but they're very similar
and that boilerplate language with
regards to um the commission and all of
those kinds of things are the
same and we have not run into fees with
that PT compact now the nursing compact
that's been in existence for a long time
if they're charging the $6,000 that's
been decided upon and they've and I'm
them well you see this is the thing
because you don't because we need
somebody who knows the answers to these
things this is the thing and I don't
know who that person is who is that
person so I've emailed on the the
finance question I've emailed our um
Director of Finance to see if he can
pull four the four compacts that oplc
belongs to and I believe there's some
compacts that other agencies belong to
but I'm talking about oplc are we
charged anything and how much because I
think that would be very helpful to you
um I just emailed him when we first
discussed this 15 minutes ago and I
haven't heard back um so on that piece
you know we can get you that
answer um as far as comparing this to
other compacts uh Tina is correct my
understanding is this is most similar to
the PT compact um they're all very
similar I haven't gone through line by
by line to to match them up and see how
they're different um you know I I can do
that if the committee wants to see um
see
this representative Roy um yeah I know
that Dan logston from CSG is is on the
call um maybe if you are can bring him
into this he he'll be able to shed some
more light on on the
questions okay I just promoted into
panelist
uh in the meantime representative
while uh so I appreciate the opportunity
to weigh in a little bit because I I I
understand that there's some skepticism
there's due diligence involved in the
subcommittee's questioning and
deliberation but uh just just a couple
of things that those of us who've been
on the committee for a while uh can
perhaps contribute that's what I'm going
to try and do in my remarks uh and that
is first of all as American citizens we
have the free right of movements within
the United States right uh we we can
move any to any state at any time uh
just as I came here 35 years ago roughly
um and so I've been a taxpayer and a
contributor to the state of New
Hampshire all along um I haven't been a
burden on the state uh hope I won't ever
be a burden on the state on other
taxpayers um but the bottom line is
everybody has a freedom of movement uh
and and the idea that we're suddenly
gonna there was a remark the question
raised earlier about we're going to be
flooded with people coming up from
Louisiana well my answer is what's the
draw to come to New
Hampshire one of the things that this
committee has been doing for virtually
the entire time that I've been on it 15
years is we've been trying to work for
better standards of reciprocity and so
forth so that we can get people that we
need in this state that is a matter that
is not being sufficiently understood
here I believe is that when we want it
when we have a shortage of nurses or
physical therapists or whatever the need
is then we want people to come here to
do those jobs because we need them and
and to the degree that the compacts
enable us to get people who are trained
skilled and so forth to come here then
that's to our advantage and we've been
doing trying to do that for
years um so the idea that we're going to
have people come sleding up here that
must mean that there is a tremendous
boom in the New Hampshire
economy I don't think it's very likely
that we're going to get a tremendous
boom but there certainly has been growth
in the New Hampshire economy for most of
my 35 years here uh and we've also had
uh additional people moving in mostly
from
Massachusetts not from Louisiana um and
they're right across the border there
are a lot of them that have settled
across the border and become New
Hampshire citizens and
taxpayers uh and and if they came and
started a business uh then they're
contributing to the tax base uh property
taxpayers and so forth and so on this is
all to the benefit of the New Hampshire
economy if you subscribe to the e to the
theory that all economic growth is good
then you want ought to want more people
now the idea that we're going to have be
flooded with anybody I think is not the
real world unless there is a tremendous
demand and if there's a tremendous
demand then we need those people to come
here to meet that demand and one of the
things we know on this committee those
of who's been here for a while is that
we have a tremendous need in mental
health in nursing and in other
especially medical Fields so this
compact is going to enable us to meet
some of those needs and the compact
Theory and principle is one that's well
established it's been working in the
state with the with regard to some of
these professions for some time and we
we we don't see the state tilting into
the ocean because to me and many people
have come flooding in uh and so
representative representative Schmid
with with all due respect I think we
we've established that we kind of like
the idea of the compact we're talking
about a the nuts and bolts of it and um
I think the rep the Louisiana was just
an example of a state where someone
could come from do you have anything add
I take your point Mr chairman and and I
and I said in my initial statement that
the skepticism and the due diligence is
appropriate but some of the ideas uh
strike me more as being you know over
suspicious as if we are the first state
to try this or as if we have never dealt
with any other kind of compact before
our experience has been good that's why
we're trying to expand it so I
appreciate the opportunity to share my
thoughts with the with the committee
goalie thank you Mr chair and I'll be
real brief I just wanted to respond to
that uh there was no influx of
louisianans coming up here uh that was
statement was not made uh in this
hearing but I also just want to remind
representative Schmidt that when folks
do come here and as he just stated uh
moving up here from Massachusetts or
wherever um out of state and moving to
New Hampshire that we heard earlier in
this hearing that once they become a
resident they will be getting a New
Hampshire license so the compact really
doesn't involve those cases thank you
okay thanks all right let's let's move
along our representative
leus um thank you Mr chair um you know
first of all I I do um want to make it
easy for people to practice uh wherever
and to move if they want um I'm
generally supportive of this um but I
think it's part of due diligence we need
to you know look at it with open eyes
and understand what's going on and you
had uh some comments about having some
control over what happened
um especially things that might generate
fees and I think you know basically if
we're going to do this we need we need
to depend on the commission being
reasonable um you know even if we put
some restrictions on what our
Representatives chose to do um they're
going to be just uh two votes on this
and um they could vote against it and
there still could be you know let's say
some large fees assessed um and that's
true and um you know I definitely
support if we can do it an amendment to
say that uh you know this has to be paid
for by oplc and and you know part of the
whole self funding thing and there's a
mechanism where we can uh
charge um you know the people who are
practicing here under the compact for it
um but uh but in the end um you know we
can't have any kind of absolute control
I don't think where the legislature
control um what they do
but and but I think that's you know the
experience shows that that hasn't been a
problem in other compacts and I'm okay
with that agree thank you uh
representative
Shu thank you Mr chair um just a quick
aside um representative Schmidt asking
what's the draw for people from
Louisiana I just promised them that they
22nd uh but I wanted to put forward if
if it wouldn't uh violate the
langage um for the compact something
along the lines of a statement any
expenses agreed to within the compact by
our representative shall be covered by
oplc funds something along those lines
just
suggesting yeah I think we all pretty
much agree with that that that would
satisfy a lot of the uh Financial
concerns we have Mr uh logon you wanted
to uh weigh in
uh uh yes uh if if if folks would like
me to I just made some notes and
appreciate um the opportunity to speak
with you all today um just to recap the
council state governments is a
membership Organization for States every
State's a member um I know you all
interact with CSG East our um uh
legislative uh affiliate out there in
the East and so just appreciate you
participating with CSG and um you know
glad to be of service to you uh the
national Center for interstate compacts
um has been working on all these
existing ler compacts in one form or
another so just quickly someone ask
about the differences I mean all these
lure compacts are similar in Form and
Function um there's essentially two
kinds so the medical compact is
expedited lier you're actually getting
licensed into the states in an expedited
manner the all the other ones are what's
called Mutual recognition compacts so
your home state license is being
mutually recognized by the other compact
member states the nursing compacts works
just like your driver's license uh when
PT uh was developing uh their compact
it's my understanding that uh the folks
developing that wanted a little bit more
visibility on who was in their states
and also what they heard from their
state boards uh was that we're concerned
about Revenue law so we'd like a
mechanism uh to be able to you know
potentially claw back some of that
Revenue I don't know if that exact
phrase was used but that's the the the
result of it and so they came up with
this privileged to practice model and um
the all the professions that we've been
working with subsequently have
gravitated toward that because it does
give the state boards the ability to
charge a fee for that uh compact
privilege and recover some of that
Revenue um so that that's one point I
wanted to make again um the back half of
all these compacts are very similar um
because they rely on that same boiler
plate language um and as far as the
assessments go I just want to address
that you know New Hampshire is a member
of a lot of compacts that assess New
Hampshire U not sure where uh the the
the end result of that money comes from
but um uh you're a member of the uh uh
the juvenile compact the compact for
juvenile offenders the interstate
compact for adult offender supervision
uh the military children's compact
commission uh the Emergency Management
assistance compact um and um uh the uh
and then all of the ler compact so uh
you know in our work with these lure
compacts and you know this absolutely is
something uh uh that I think speaks to
to what you're talking about here you
know I think the goal of all these
compacts are to be self- sustaining and
to rely on assistance from um board
organizations national board
organization and National membership
organizations but yes there there is
that assessment language there because
we insist on it this benefits the states
um we're not encouraging an assessment
toward the states but it would be
irresponsible to create something like
an interstate compact commission which
is an instrumentality of the states it's
a quasa governmental agency it's Supra
state but it's subf Federal and it's
accountable to the state so um without
you know having having that assessment
but I think their all of their intention
is is to limit as much as possible any
assessment on the states um and
certainly just something about I know
there's been a lot of talk about you
know these folks are empowered to speak
on on behalf of our state um you know
what kind of recourse do we had and
another uh speaker really hit it on the
head I mean these are public meetings
the agendas will be published well in
advance um you know the compact
Commissioners aren't just going to show
up at the meeting and get presented with
something and vote on it um you know the
the agencies that appoint the
Commissioners are going to have
visibility on what's going to happen at
the meetings and we'll instruct their
delegates uh at least this is how it
happens with the other compacts I don't
know why it wouldn't happen with this
one they'll instruct their delegates uh
how to proceed and how to vote and you
know this compact like all of them um
you know this is an extreme remedy but
but they do have a withdraw provision so
um you know this isn't the the Hotel
California I mean you you can check out
and you can actually leave uh at some
point you're not you have to meet your
obligations but um but if the compact
commission was to do something so
honorous that the legislature in New
Hampshire said that's it we're getting
out you can get out you have to get out
the same way you joined but but there is
is that uh is that provision there's
also a lot of Provisions around
mediation uh that that we would hope uh
States would take advantage of so uh end
though but this is an instrumentality of
the states it's accountable to the
states um and you know you have the
power to uh provide as much oversight as
as you wish to provide okay thank you
secretary if I could ask a quick
question and that is Mr logon uh um
what's your position or who do you
represent oh I'm sorry my name is uh I
apologize um my name is Dan Lon I am the
director of the national Center for
interstate compacts at the Council of
state governments and again all of you
are members of the council state
governments we're a nonpartisan
nonprofit membership Organization for
States you uh representative gr go ahead
you're
muted right so does your organization or
do these all these compacts that we
belong to do they send out annual
reports that's a great question um yes
uh they well they compile and ex uh uh
the reports and they're provided to
their state commissioner now um whether
it's provided to the legislature I can't
speak speak to representative but yes
the large National compacts like the
interstate compact for adult offender
supervision and the juvenile Compact and
the military children's Compact and the
Emergency Management compact uh and the
interstate compact for the placement of
children which deals with kids and
Foster Care uh they all put together
annual reports if you Google them you
can find their websites and get access
to those reports if it would be helpful
I can certainly um um uh get links and
send those over to you all as well could
you please send those to us because I
this is important information that we
need to know I me I had no I had no idea
that we we belong to so many compacts
and I think it would be a good place it
would be good for a place to keep that
on our State website sure absolutely
thank you and just to respond to what
you said about um Mr Lon about the we
belong to so many compacts I guess the
difference is the uh on this particular
one um I'm chairing the subcommittee and
I'm not going to sign up on something
until I know what it's going to cost us
um but having said that I think that
we've come to a a quasi consensus that
um we need some language that says
opsc is going to be responsible for any
fees generated by this
um does that sound does everybody sound
like we want that Tony you have your
hand
up uh sorry I just hadn't dropped it but
I I do agree with that okay uh
representative Gord do you agree with
that yes I do and representative uh
goalie yes I do Mr chair okay um uh who
who could get us that language would
that be you Mr
Brader yes I'm happy to um draft
something up or
um I of course will need to run it by my
executive director I do not see her
having an issue with this but um I'll
get on a call with her after this
meeting some something very simple short
sweet any fees that are required uh as a
as a condition of our membership in this
compact will be funded by the oplc and
um just to be clear if I may um I know
we've been primarily talking about the
first compact in this lead uh this bill
the speech language pathology Audiology
there's also that the nearly identical
OT compact um you want that to cover
both yeah I would I'm basically treating
these as the same thing just different
professions but the nuts and bolts of it
um that we're responsible for should be
same okay check we also get uh from them
if there's any fees that we are
currently paying into these compacts as
are yeah if anyone has that information
I would like to see that as well what
what we're currently paying um in
compact fees and how they're being paid
um that would be great so do you think
we can get all this together um within a
week Mr brri absolutely I I um I just
heard from Miss Adams that they have
language we might be able to tweak so I
would imagine by the end of this week
yeah end of this
week okay so I I will um I will we have
we have language on on this we can help
with okay great I'll let you guys handle
that and get me the language and then
I'll request an amendment
um so I'm going to confer with the
chairman uh uh um representative Maguire
and committee staff to set a date for
another hearing um to finish this out um
it it may be um I think it has to be
next week I'd rather it wasn't because
I'm going to be in Florida but I can do
this from the beach I think um so I will
get back to everybody on this and we
will post the date for the next hearing
does anyone else have anything before we
close it out
no thank you thank you thank you all
very much for your assistance and we'll
speak soon yes safe in Florida yes I I